Speaker 1: All right. So I teased this story
earlier, and I think it's a really important one,
because it is exactly the type of deception
and stochastic terrorism, quite frankly, that
will lead to real world violence. The headline
that started floating around is Democrats have
started killing Republicans. Democrats are just
murdering Republicans. And the questions are,
where did that come from and where is this
supposedly happening? Well, where it came from
is a Republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
GREENE speaking at the Trump rally in Warren,
Michigan, over the weekend. Daily Beast
covered it. Many media outlets covered
it. And the headlines are something like.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE says Democrats have
started killings of Republicans. Let's listen to
what she had to say. And as is often the case,
actually, you know, what should I explain now?
Let's play it first. Let's just play it. And
then there's plenty to talk about here.
Speaker 2: We're all targets now, though,
for daring to push back against the regime. And
it doesn't stop at a weaponized legal system.
Speaker 1: By the way, use of the word regime to
suggest that the Biden administration is anything
other than a democratically elected presidency.
Speaker 2: I'm not
going to mince words with you all. Democrats want
Republicans dead, and they've already started the
killings. An 18 year old boy was run down by
a Democrat driver who confessed to killing the
teenager simply because he was a Republican.
Speaker 1: That's not true. And I'll tell you
about it later.
Speaker 2:
Even right here in Michigan. Just last
week, an 83 year old woman was shot in
the back for advocating for the unborn.
Speaker 1: That is also not true. And I
will tell you about that story in a minute.
Speaker 2: Joe Biden has declared every
freedom loving American an enemy of
the state. But under Republicans,
we will take back our country from the Communists
who have stolen it and want us to disappear.
We will expose the unelected bureaucrats,
the real enemies within who have abused
their power and declared political warfare.
Speaker 1: All right. So, first of all,
there are no communists that have taken over. Joe
Biden is not a communist. The communists and the
socialists really don't like Biden because they
say he's basically just a centrist Republican
light capitalist. Okay. So there's no communists
here. That's just nonsense. The rhetoric
that Marjorie Taylor GREENE is using there is
completely unacceptable. And it is very dangerous
because the lunatics in the audience will hear it
and they'll believe it. And then they might go go
and say, well, listen, if the Democrats are
just killing Republicans on site, then we can
do the same. But understand that the stories that
Marjorie Taylor GREENE told aren't true. She says
a Democrat ran over a Republican because he was a
Republican, just ran him over with his car. What
happened and you can Google the story to morons
more than likely got into a political argument.
We don't know whether alcohol or substances were
a factor, but two people got into an argument.
It was an argument about politics. The argument
escalated and one of them jumped in his car and
hit the other person with his car. It was a
Democrat who hit a Republican. It's wrong.
It's a crime. Political discussions should never
escalate to that. Should be charge. Should be
punished if convicted. But Marjorie Taylor GREENE
wants you to think some guy just drove by someone
with a MAGA hat that he didn't know and ran
him over like it's just some kind of street
assassination. This was a an argument that became
a fight that went crazy. Crimes were committed.
Punish the criminals. But it's not. My neighbor
is a Democrat. I'm going to go run them over.
It didn't happen. Okay, then she says an 83 year
old woman was shot for advocating for the unborn.
That's not what happened. Okay, Google the
story. A man in Michigan was charged for
shooting an elderly woman in an altercation
that involved an accidental shooting.
Richard Harvey is 74 years old. The story,
as far as we know right now is that John
Jacobsen was campaigning door to door in
Michigan against abortion. That part is true.
John Jacobsen came to the door of the Harvey's.
Harvey and his wife were arguing they'd had a
disagreement with the woman who was going
door to door, arguing against abortion.
And then at a certain point, the guy grabbed his.
What are the details? You grabbed his rifle? A 22.
Grabbed a 22. The rifle belonged to the guy's wife
and said, hey, you got to get out of here. You got
to get out of here. And fired a warning shot
at a tree. Now it's already wrong. I'm already
completely against it. Okay. Then he says that he,
quote, without thinking, tried to hit the woman's
clipboard out of her hands with the rifle, and
at that point, he accidentally shot the woman. So
negligent discharge should be charged with a crime
if the investigation determines one was committed,
as I always say. But it was not a story. The
way Marjorie Taylor GREENE paints it is there
was a pro-life event and a guy showed up with
a rifle and shot a pro-life protester. This
was another one of these outer altercation,
confrontation things. I'm not defending them,
but they are not the lurid assassinations. I
mean, that that Marjorie Taylor GREENE claims
them to be. Trump does this a lot during his
speeches. Trump will tell stories like we just
saw the conviction of an illegal immigrant who was
released into the public and shot someone dead.
Right. And then you look up the story and the
crime happened when Trump was president. Yes. Now
they were convicted. But what does it matter? The
crime happened when Trump was president, trying to
make the point that under Biden, these things
are happening, even though it happened under
Trump in some of these cases. Look up every one of
these. And, of course, extraordinarily dangerous,
because when people on the right hear these
stories, they become more likely on average to act
out in violent ways because they believe that the
left is doing it. Extraordinarily dangerous stuff